today on the matt wells show proponents
of critical race theory are now claiming
that all they want to do is teach kids
about the facts of american history
facts like slavery that's all they want
to do it's all critical race there
is uh and and they're wrong about that
that's not all the critical race theory
is of course but i think we should teach
about slavery too
but we should be telling the whole truth
and today we'll talk about the whole
truth of slavery also five headlines
the nsa denies tucker carlson's claim
that he's being spied on or did they
really deny it
a man is crowned miss nevada usa and a
woman whose husband is active duty navy
alerts me to a mandatory diversity hike
quote unquote in honor of pride month
that her husband was allegedly forced to
participate in in our daily cancellation
a new organization of gen
z republicans has a plan for connecting
with today's youth
and it's terrible all of that and more
today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
i've told you about how we were on
vacation and traveling and uh that's
always a lot
of fun but one of the problems when
you're when you're traveling
is that you can encounter whether you're
at a hotel or at someone's house
you encounter there are a lot of
uncomfortable beds and mattresses out
there that you have to deal with and i
know that for me
i was just waiting until i could get
home to my helix sleep mattress again
because nothing beats a helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back your stomach
whatever your sleep preferences are with
helix there's a specific mattress for
each and everybody's
unique taste helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
and if you want to know why all you got
to do is get a helix mattress
just go to helixsleep.com walsh take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders
for our listeners at helixsleep.comwalsh
that's helixsleep.comwalls for up to 200
off your mattress order
as critical race theory faces
ever-mounting criticism the strategy of
its proponents is to start throwing mud
in the water
they can't stand by their real beliefs
or defend what they're actually doing
so instead they try to turn the
discussion about critical race theory
into something else entirely
we've talked about that already but the
the efforts are getting more and more
desperate
so henry rogers stage name ibram x candy
uh went on msnbc yesterday and claimed
that he doesn't believe that white
people are inherently racist let's
listen to that
do you believe that white americans are
inherently racist
oh i do not and indeed in how to be an
anti-racist
i make the case that we shouldn't
believe that anyone
is inherently racist or that we should
identify anyone
as a racist whoa
what we shouldn't identify anyone as a
racist well that's
that's news to everyone including to
henry rogers himself who
not long ago was saying stuff like this
it is critical for for white people for
people
uh in general to stop denying
their their racist ideas to stop denying
the ways in which policies have
benefited them to stop denying
their racism and to realize that
actually the heartbeat of racism itself
is denial and the sound of that
heartbeat is i'm not racist
uh okay so white people aren't
inherently racist
and we shouldn't call people racist but
at the same time white people need to
stop denying that they're racist
and when they deny that they're racist
it only proves
that they're racist this would seem to
be a rather
confusing set of ideas until you realize
that it's not a set of ideas at all
there are no set ideas the ideas and
claims
change in order to accommodate the
rhetorical needs of the moment
fortunately for mr rogers
he feels no moral obligation to be
honest he has a moral obligation to be
honest same as anyone else but he
doesn't feel it being a congenital
liar and all another strategy is to
change the subject
and pretend that the argument is about
something else
entirely it's to pretend that the people
opposed to critical race theory
education
are really opposed to education in
general
so i thought this is a great example of
this strategy this is a video of a
teacher
offering a response to critical race
theory critics
and she kind of demonstrates this
approach let's uh let's listen to that
a response to republicans whenever you
say we should teach about slavery or the
genocide of indigenous people in the
classroom
is oh what happened so long ago why do
we have to why do we why do they need to
know why does anyone need to know
okay why do you learn about the
holocaust why do you learn about the
rwandan genocide
why do you learn about imperialism why
do you learn about the enlightenment why
do you learn about the soviet union
why do you know about the american
revolution why are you learning about
the civil war
all those things were in the past why
why do we learn about them
it's it's almost as though
there's a class you take in school
where you talk about things that
happened in the in the past
wait a minute wait this is all making
too much sense right
it's too much no
got to say see-through shirt interesting
choice for the classroom
uh but look i don't mean to pick on this
one teacher i do mean to pick on her
actually but not just her
this is a common enough talking point to
warrant a thorough response i think the
claim is that republicans
and by that she means anyone who's not
firmly and totally on her ideological
side on every issue
are opposed to kids being taught about
slavery or the quote genocide of native
americans
and that we don't want these things
taught because they happened a long time
ago and therefore nobody needs to know
the problem with the argument as she
presents it is that literally
not one single person has ever made that
argument she's the first one to make it
nobody and i really do mean nobody is
suggesting that the fact
of american slavery should not be taught
i have not heard anyone say that
and i would defy anyone to provide an
example of anyone saying that
it'd be quite convenient if we would
make that argument because it's a very
stupid
argument and easy to debunk but that's
not the argument
so since she brought up the subject let
me now um explain
and this is all very tied into the to
the critical race theory discussion
especially as the proponents try to
change the subject
um so so let me explain
what our point as it pertains to slavery
actually is and really there are two
points and they're both
rather simple one
the full story and truth about slavery
should be taught if we're going to tell
kids about slavery and we should
then we need to give them the complete
picture so far from wanting nothing
taught about slavery
we actually want more to be taught about
it
we want more said we want more time
spent on it the fact that so many
americans think slavery is a uniquely
white sin
and that white americans carry some kind
of special guilt for it only shows that
the education they're being given about
slavery
is narrow and incomplete we want to
widen the lens
expand the scope of the discussion
consider these questions how many
americans know
that slavery was still practiced legally
in africa as recently as 1980.
if you're in my generation my generation
was
walking this earth or at least crawling
on it um
at a time when there was still legal
slavery in the world in africa how many
americans know that
how many realize that it was practiced
legally all across the non-western world
long after it had been abolished
everywhere in the western world
how many realize that it still goes on
unofficially
quote unquote in africa the mideast and
asia
how many even realize that slavery is an
ancient institution which predates the
formation of the united states by many
thousands of years
how many know that by the time white
americans were buying slaves
the practice had already been in place
in the middle east for 8
000 years how many know that it had been
going on for thousands of years in the
americas before the white man showed up
how many know that black americans and
native americans
both owned black slaves
i think the answer on all counts is very
few
very few people in this country know any
of those facts
i believe they should know those facts
which means that i want far
more to be taught about slavery my
problem with the slavery education being
provided
by women like the one in that video is
that it doesn't go nearly far enough
do any of the facts i just listed
minimize
the objective evil of american slavery
no
do they potentially mitigate the
personal moral culpability of the
individuals in this country who
supported it or practiced it
yes of course i mean someone who
practiced slavery today
someone who practices slavery today and
again people do practice it today
is more morally culpable than someone
who practiced it
200 years ago the fact that slavery was
an accepted institution the world over
for thousands and thousands of years
everywhere does not again make it less
objectively evil but it does call for
the actions of the individuals
who are involved in it to be judged
within their historical context
and and uh and yet none of that is
really the point
we should teach the full truth about
slavery simply because it's the full
truth
when we teach kids about science or
technology or mathematics
do we pretend that all of those things
were invented by and started with white
americans
do we tell kids in school that americans
invented democracy or poetry or
literature
no you see when it comes to the good
things the things of value
we make sure that our children know that
other people throughout history and
around the world contributed
and yet with slavery we tend to take all
the credits
funny how that works isn't it that's our
first point about slavery the second
is that no person living today
should be made to feel any guilt at all
for atrocities that happened before they
were born slavery included
and this is a really fortunate thing
because there's a very good chance
that all of us every person alive today
is descended from slave owners at some
point back in their family tree
now i know that i'm not descended from
white american slave owners
my family got here after
that was all done but uh but
some far-removed relative way back there
my lineage
probably owned some slaves somewhere at
some point that's true for you too
it's true for everyone black white or
otherwise
you've also most likely had relatives
who murdered who robbed who committed
other
unknown acts of savagery the world is a
brutal place today and it used to be a
whole lot more brutal
nobody's ancestral line is pure or clean
so
we can all be weighed down by guilt for
things we didn't do and had no hand in
and which occurred before we even
existed or we can carry on with our
lives
i suggest the latter in fact i don't
think
that you should even necessarily be
weighed down by guilt for things
that you did do if you did something bad
and you feel guilty as you should um
then make amends the best you can
apologize to the person you wrong
repent of your sins change your ways
make your act of contrition but there's
nothing to be gained
no virtue to be found in walking around
every day utterly obsessed with and
possessed by
the sins of your past for which you've
already repented and here i refer again
to the sins of
your past even those should not consume
you
but the sins of someone else's past sins
in which you played absolutely
no part whatsoever
if you feel guilt about that then your
situation is uh pathological
and those are my points about slavery
i think i can generally speak for for
all conservatives really
on this this is what we're saying about
slavery
yes teach about it but teach the right
things
teach the full picture and don't cast
blame where it doesn't belong
that's it pretty simple now let's get to
our five headlines
we take a lot of pictures these days
because we all carry
uh cameras or it used to be kids don't
realize this but it used to be that you
had a camera which was a separate
thing that you had to like bring with
you if you thought you were doing
something or you might want to take a
picture but now everybody has a camera
with them
and uh so we're taking pictures all the
time i don't really but my wife does
everything we do she's like we got to
take 45 pictures and document every
aspect of this but you know what happens
you take the pictures and then and then
what do you do with them they're just
they stay on your phone
and then you go and get a new phone
eventually and you lose half of them and
they're just kind of there in cyberspace
you're not doing anything with them
uh and that's why if you take a picture
you need to find a way to cherish that
moment and you can do that by making it
physical so that
that moment you captured doesn't get
lost on your camera roll
and that's why you need myphoto.com it's
awesome and easy to use and it takes
literally two minutes to create a
special product for your own wall or
shelf
and they make great gifts for your loved
ones my photo prints your image directly
on acrylic glass metal and more
you need to go to myphoto.com and check
it out that's my photo.com order today
you're 20
off your order which will arrive in just
five days prices start at just
twelve dollars use code walsh and get
twenty percent off today
at myphoto.com
all right so uh you know i'm still kind
of new to city life
we moved from a rural town in
pennsylvania
literally a one-stop sign we didn't have
to stop play with a stop sign
and uh we had like a post office and a
bar you know gassy
uh my point is that i'm i'm still kind
of getting accustomed to city life
and uh and and feeling my ways through
things a little bit
maybe with some naivete um i don't know
so i made a mistake
i guess it was a mistake last night
um when i went to a mexican uh takeout
place well first of all my my wife and
kids i really like to blame this on my
wife because she's not here
my wife and kids are gone for the week
and so i'm home alone and my wife said
uh that she would
she said oh i can order you some
groceries and uh because she doesn't
trust me just go buy this so she should
order should i order him send them to
the house
and you know you can make meals and i
said do you think i'm gonna make meals
for myself when i'm home alone
well who do you think i am no i'm just
gonna order takeout that's what i'm
gonna live on of course
so what does mexican take out place and
um
and there were bars in the windows and
there was there's no ac
everybody's everybody's sweating up a
storm in the whole place
but the tacos were like a buck 50 a
piece so i figured it'd be fine and then
i
ate it um a lot of tacos probably too
many and i i just i lived
to pay the price i'm not going to go
into detail but then i thought is this
is this something you should do
basically should you avoid places with
bars in the window when it comes to
ordering food i don't know
and the problem might have been that as
i was starting to feel
the pain and discomfort of my decision i
thought well let me settle my stomach a
little bit i went to my fridge and i
pulled out the
takeout leftover indian that i had eaten
the day before
and i started eating that because i
thought maybe that would help
it didn't help at all it was all
information you didn't need but now
you have it here's information you do
you do need i think the nsa
has been accused by tucker carlson of
spying on him in order to get the show
put off the air and he said that a
whistleblower we talked about this
yesterday a whistleblower in the nsa
reached out to him and told him this was
happening
and then also repeated back to him some
messages that he had
sent that there's no way that should be
known unless he was being spied on the
nsa has issued a statement
regarding these allegations and let's
just i'll read the statement to you
and listen very carefully to each
sentence because this is the nsa we're
talking about
and they don't have some 17 year old
intern putting out statements on stuff
like this
there's a lot of thought put into each
sentence
so you got to pay attention to what is
said and what's not said
so the statement is on june 28
2021 tucker carlson alleged that the
national security agency has been
monitoring our electronic communications
and is planning to leak them in an
attempt to take this show off the air
this allegation is untrue tucker carlson
has never been an intelligence target of
the agency and the nsa has never had any
plans to try to take his program off the
air
nsa has a foreign intelligence mission
we target foreign powers to generate
insights on foreign activities that
could harm the united states
with limited exceptions like an
emergency
nsa may not target a u.s citizen without
a court order that explicitly authorizes
the targeting
now the media has reported this as a
full denial and
[Music]
full transparency from the nsa
but i read this and i think okay this is
a little interesting
because because actually there are three
claims that tucker carlson makes
he's making a three-fold allegation
it's really three separate allegations
it's that his
communications are being monitored and
that
there's a plan to leak them and that
this is being done to take him off the
air
so the nsa in their statement they
repeat this and then they say
this allegation is untrue well hang on a
second nsa
wish allegation is untrue because there
are three of them you denied
one are you saying the whole thing is
untrue or just the last thing you said
or what and again there's
there's a lot of thought put into this
they could have said
all of this is untrue or these
allegations
are untrue instead they say this
allegation is untrue
and then rather than saying we have
never
monitored tucker carlson or we have
never accessed any
private information or any messages or
emails or anything instead of saying
that which they could have said
they say tucker carlson has never been
an intelligence target of the agency
was somebody else a target
and tucker carlson got wrapped up into
that was he
monitored for some other reason without
being an intelligence target
i'm not going to say that their denial
fully confirms that the claim is true
but um
i i would say it it it is more evidence
in fact
that at least some of what is being
claimed is true
because they could have denied the
entire thing in a very
clear and direct way and they didn't i
mean anytime someone denies
you know you make a claim and then they
rephrase your claim
in a different way and deny the
rephrased version of it
yeah that that's always a red flag
because sergeant carlson says they
monitor me they have my messages and the
nsa says
uh no you've never been a target
well hold on that's that's not exactly
what i said
all right let's go uh next here this is
from the new york post it says a
transgender woman
quote unquote uh that would be a male
has been crowned miss nevada usa for the
first time in the pageant's history
cataluna enriquez
27 who only began competing last year
in cisgender pageants was named the
winner sunday in the competition at the
southpointe hotel casino in las vegas
enriquez said one thing that's important
for me is inclusivity diversity and
representation
it's something i did not have growing up
and is still lacking in today's world
today i am a proud transgender woman of
color personally i've learned that my
differences do not make me less than it
makes me more than
i didn't i hadn't actually read this
story until right now
uh i did i didn't you know once you see
the headline you kind of get the gist of
it
but that is just great isn't that my
differences don't make me less then it
makes me more
more than what more than who i should
ask
well we know exactly what it means and
the people who run miss nevada usa
apparently agree i'm i'm
better than uh than actual women
i'm not just uh the equal to a woman or
the same as i'm
i'm a better version
because i'm a man men are better at
everything apparently i mean they're
better men are better at being women
than women
this this is the message we keep getting
from our culture over and over again as
more and more men
win these uh various competitions that
are met for women
whether it's athletics or now beauty
pageants
caitlyn jenner woman of the year
the message is that men are just men
make better women
that's the message i certainly don't
agree with that
that's what we're being told
you know we we hear so much from
feminists about
misogyny you know
the patriarchy and so on
and every time they talk about it
whatever direction they're pointing in
it's not there
but here's here's a real example of it i
don't know if i would call this the
patriarchy because i'm not exactly sure
what that even is
um but i would call this misogyny
yeah i don't know what else to call it a
man standing up on stage and saying he's
more than these other women
other women these women i'm not sure
what else to call
that's like the definition of misogyny
a man saying i'm better than women isn't
that misogyny
uh staying with the lgbt theme for a
moment here a woman
sent me something through private
message that um
i'm sure the nsa has already seen so i
might as well tell you about it as well
uh so her her husband is active duty
navy
and she sent me this um
with a couple of pictures here she said
that there what she said was that there
was a
diversity hike quote unquote
in honor of pride month and uh
that the message came down from command
that this was mandatory
that's what she she said that it was
mandatory and
there were no exceptions there was no
excused absence you had to show up
and she provided a picture of the flyer
it says you can see the flyer there
lgbtq pride month diversity hike
uh when the 25th of june
um uh attire pride attire color for
clothing
and why we will support our brothers and
sisters whom are a part of the pride
community
and then you can see the picture there
if it wasn't bad enough and disturbing
enough you look at the picture look at
that picture
there there you see a rainbow american
flag
this was uh in an official event
put on by the military
they might not be in military uniform
but it's an event and
you've got people in the military
marching under a rainbow american flag
i mean i don't know call me
old-fashioned or something i don't think
that
anyone in our military should ever march
under any flag
other than the united states flag the
real united states flag not
not a gayified version of it
now um you could see here
just based on the photographs there's
plenty of evidence that this thing
actually happened
and um in fact you can go to the
facebook page
where this was advertised and you can
see that yeah this really happened as
far as the claim that it's mandatory
that's that's what she told me i haven't
seen any confirmation about that
and given the circumstance and that this
is the military this could have been one
of those things where
uh it's mandatory and it's you're made
to understand that you need to show up
but we can't actually tell you that it's
mandatory it's kind of
mandatory being communicated through a
wink sort of thing
i'm not sure but mandatory or not
there's no excuse for this at all
the diversity hike
while other while other countries
militaries are
you know focused on getting stronger
getting more lethal
getting better at killing the enemy
[Music]
ours uh ours are having diversity hikes
in honor of pride month under a rainbow
flag
all right next year we have some sad
news today reported by the miami herald
it says quote the feds have indicted
rapper pooh sheisty
over the alleged shooting and robbery of
two men outside of a bay
harbor islands hotel the rapper whose
real name is lontrell williams is now in
federal custody
and made his first miami federal court
appearance on tuesday afternoon
the charge is discharging a firearm
during a violent crime conspiracy and
robbery under a law regulating commerce
williams 21 had been charged and freed
on bond in miami miami-dade
state court over the same incident but
earlier this month he was put back in
jail on a separate charge over the
alleged shooting of a security guard
at the king of diamond strip club on
memorial day
now i'm sorry but i have to say i i
can't believe that poo scheisse would do
this
um this is not the push isd that i know
the push isd that i know okay is a
gentleman
he's easily the most decent and
courteous man to ever bear the name
pooh sheisty and now you expect me to
believe he did something like this
listen to the details of this crime okay
one of the crimes it sounds like there
are a bunch of crimes
but there's one of them anyway it says
according to a criminal complaint the
trio
in october arranged to buy some
marijuana and high-end athletic sneakers
from two men at the landon hotel in bay
harbor islands
williams showed up in a in a rented
mclaren exotic car
um and uh and then during the deal
williams and brown shot the two men one
in the hip the other in the rear end
according to the complaint
the robbery was captured on video
surveillance according to the criminal
complaint
williams used a draco subcompact machine
gun
and never paid either victim for the
shoes or marijuana
well i would guess not generally when
you're shooting someone in order to
steal you don't you don't pay but um
shot the man in the ass over a pair of
shoes
now i ask i ask you does that sound like
something pooch isd would do
you tell me and keep in mind something
else here too uh the internet tells me
that poo sheisty recently linked up
um and did a song with a fellow named
spotum got him
and uh i think do we have a picture of
spottom got him i just thought it was
important
there we go so there's spotum got him
okay he appears to be nine years old and
it would seem that his barber prefers to
use
a weed whacker or maybe like a food
processor than
traditional clippers but anyway
with friends like these influences like
look at spotum gotham
this is a man who pays his taxes this is
a man who recycles
with friends and influences like these
would poo scheiste resort to criminal
behavior
come on free poo
that's what i say that's that's that is
the banner that i will march under
free poo okay
um next year we got we got a bunch of
other things
actually a million things to talk about
and my the editors probably hate me
because i sent them like 40 clips that i
wanted to play and i'll play about two
of them
um but we also have this
james from the daily wire james corden
announced recently that he would change
the spill your guts
segment on the late late show which was
previously accused of being culturally
offensive because some of the disgusting
foods it featured were dishes from asian
countries
so this is uh apparently a segment that
i've never seen
because i don't watch that show at all
uh absolutely no interest but
in the segment it's just segment
centered around the
the comedy is is you bring a famous
person on
and there's a bunch of disgusting food
and then i guess it's
you're asked kind of like a truth or
dare situation where you're asked a
question if you don't want to
answer the question you have to eat the
disgusting food and sometimes the
disgusting food that's featured
is asian food and this segment had been
happening on the show for years and no
one had a problem with it
and then one tick tock influencer
noticed it and
decreed that it was racist and that was
enough for james corden to say oh you
know what you're right
this thing that i've been doing for
years and never occurred to me there was
any problem with it
since since you random person have told
me it's racist then it must be
so he was on the howard stern show he
was asked about this he said we heard
about the backlash and the next time we
do that bit we absolutely won't use any
of those foods
our show is a show about joy and light
and love
we don't want to make a show that will
upset anybody we completely understand
the backlash you said um i don't know
when we're going to do that bit again
we we when we do we absolutely won't use
any foods that offend
and he goes on and says it's not for us
to determine why somebody's upset or
hurt about something
that's not for us to decide all we can
do is go
all right we get it we hear you we won't
do that
no that's not all you can do all when
someone says they're upset all we can do
the only thing we can do is just say
fine we'll stop doing whatever upsets
you that's all we can do
no there's there's something else you
can do you know what else you can do
uh you can look them in the eyes and you
can say i don't care that you're upset
you're being ridiculous i'm gonna keep
doing what i was doing before
that's also an option you could do that
too
this this defensiveness that people get
over over
you know food especially with asian food
now we have to treat it with this uh
with this reverence
if if you say anything negative about
asian food it's re you can't be racist
against
food
and yes different cultures have
different food that they
like to eat and probably every culture
has something that they eat that other
cultures will look at that and say
that's disgusting
and in the past we could just we could
laugh about that
that's how you know you've made real
progress
when it comes to racial and ethnic
relations
um it you know you've made real progress
when you can laugh about things it's
just like that's how you know that
you're you're friends with someone
when you can laugh at them and they can
laugh at you and nobody gets offended
so it was progress before
when you could do when a couple of white
people could do a segment
where they're eating some food that
maybe in asia is
is is traditional and and is considered
a delicacy
but here it's it's weird and gross
and we can all just laugh about it
but no no now there are land mines
everywhere and everyone's offended by
everything and that's
what that's supposed to be progress by
the way no surprise here as usa today
reports the tick tocker who started the
backlash
by the name of kim sarah isn't happy
with corden's apology
who would have thought so sarah told
kcrw
um according to usa today i feel like
there's no accountability on his end
i think that the line was really drawn
when he decided to mock foods that are
used in predominantly asian cultures
there are ways to go about comedy that
don't offend or
and aren't culturally insensitive
actually there aren't
there is no way to go about comedy um
that that won't offend somebody
or maybe put it another way if your
first
priority in comedy is to not offend
anybody
then you're not doing comedy
the the first priority of comedy should
be to to be funny
you put anything above that and it's not
really comedy and certainly if you're if
your
first priority is defensive or you don't
want to offend anyone then that's not
comedy
more from the new york post on this
person's feelings and why this person's
feelings
matter has not been explained um but
apparently she's been all over the media
talking about how the harm that was
caused to her by this segment that again
has been going on for years and didn't
bother anybody
but she saw it and it's j is she deeply
wounded by it
um it's kind of discouraging that he
hasn't put out an apology because i
really want this all to just
end he doesn't have to apologize to me
he just needs to apologize to the asian
community
and recognize the harm that it caused
the asian people
what harm exactly can you explain that
kim
i want you to go into real detail with
this explain to me in detail
i want this the full step-by-step
process
uh we're starting with james corden
eating a food on camera and laughing
about how it grows
and then somewhere down the line here
asian people are harmed how does that
work
i know he doesn't need to apologize to
the asian community because the asian
community wasn't offended
even if they were just because someone's
offended doesn't mean you owe an apology
but it's not the age it's you
you're the one everybody else was fine
with it you're the one who was offended
you know what i'd also like to know is
uh i don't know all the foods that they
were eating i know one of them
is i forget the name of it but um
there's a in some cultures they'll eat
it's basically a hard-boiled egg
[Music]
but there's a like a fertilized
fetal duck or chicken inside it that
you're eating
um another that's that's i saw in a clip
that's one of the foods that they ate
which apparently i guess in some asian
cultures
is traditional i'm i'm curious kimcera
would would you eat that
or would you think that that's
disgusting
all right a story from a few days ago
that i never got a chance to talk about
from the blaze
um it says quote many medical experts
have claimed
that there are no health drawbacks to
wearing face masks masks for long
periods of time
as long as you regularly clean them or
use a new covering each time you mask up
but florida parents
who are concerned about children wearing
face masks at school discovered recently
that face masks actually catch a host of
bacteria
many of which are dangerous pathogens
the gainesville parents
sent six recently worn face masks to the
university of florida for laboratory
testing
they discovered that the face masks
collect numerous bacteria that cause in
many cases
serious illness who would have thought
uh the 11
dangerous pathogens found on the masks
are responsible for illnesses that
include
pneumonia turbo tuberculosis meningitis
sepsis
e coli diphtheria lyme disease
and urinary tract infections
these again are the pathogens
that are found in these masks that kids
are wearing all day
yet another revelation to come out of
the covid response that most of us knew
from the very beginning
[Music]
you look you put a face mask on anyone
all day
when face masks once again were never
meant to be worn that way
face masks are supposed to be worn in a
clinical setting
for limited periods of time you're not
supposed to put on a face mask and just
wear it for 12 hours
as you go about your daily activities
so you're going to find those kind of
pathogens on anyone's face mask
but especially a child
all parents all reasonable rational
parents know this
you send your your eight-year-old boy
off to school
and he's there for six hours and he come
when he walks back in the door you know
he
it it it looks like he's been rolling
around in a literal pig style all day he
looks like he's been working at the barn
his clothes are filthy his shirt is this
you just want to pick you just want to
take his shirt off and throw it away you
don't even
want to watch it looks toxic because
kids are dirty
and now you put a mask over their mouth
all day
just think about how gross that is
so there are the the medical and
physical risks of doing that
and exposing them to those having them
stew in germs all day on their face
you gotta weigh that again against the
risk of covid
which is extremely extremely small given
that they're kids
all right number five i need to play
this for you as well before we move on
because this is important to me
especially now
um that we have the bicep cam here the
bistep
bicep cam is proof that i'm an advocate
of physical fitness
and that means that i'm especially
disturbed by the epidemic of poor
form in the execution of push-ups um
this is a real crisis in our country and
has been for a long time in my opinion
and so i can't let this slide senators
tom cotton and chuck grassley were at
some sort of iowa republican party event
and for unexplained reasons they both
hit the deck and did push-ups for the
crowd
i don't know why now grassley is like
600 years old and
and so maybe he has an excuse but cotton
not so much
and i just want you to see these put
let's let's watch and count how many
real push-ups are
cause if you do look if you're doing
push-ups on a stage in front of people
you're gonna get judged on them so let's
let's let's play this video and watch
how many push-ups do we see
executed uh let's see here go ahead and
play it
zero zero zero zero
zero still haven't seen a push-up zero
zero zero zero
these are not push-ups
okay first of all you need actually
chuck grassley's form is a little bit
better
i'd like to see his i'd like to see his
feet a little bit closer together
but tom cotton look at him bobbing his
head up again
no this is not this is not a practice
and getting a concussion you don't you
don't bang your forehead on the ground
you're doing a push-up
you want to keep your neck straight
you're looking slightly up
now they had their they had their uh
their our their hands
a little bit more than shoulder width
apart that's correct
and especially for a younger guy like
tom cotton i want to see you go
down and i want to see your your your
chest hit the deck or at least get six
inches from the floor
there are some people who say as long as
you get a 90 degree angle in your arms
that that counts as a push-up i don't
think so
[Music]
so those are not real push-ups this is a
big problem in our society
people who can't do but i see it at the
gym all the time
zero true push-ups were completed just
there
but how old chuck grassley is i think
he's 87 or something
that is somewhat impressive i'll give
him an excuse all right um let's go to
the youtube comments
and red x pen says i'm not even a
conservative but boy do i like watching
matt nowadays his takes are fire
well not a conservative but i honestly
i'm not
well i guess i don't want to discourage
you but when i hear that from people
sometimes
sometimes i'll hear like leftists tell
me that they watch the show
and i think i don't even know how you
can stomach it but i'm glad you do
um andrew schnick says matt walsh please
mention that june is national dairy
month i will not mention that i refuse
um cody says matt going to be in
nashville in a couple of weeks want to
hang out i'll bring the bass boat keep
up the good work
if you can show me how to actually catch
fish in this damn state
uh i yes we can hang out um
another comment says what has
conservatism conserved exactly
yeah it's a question i get all the time
what is conservatism conserved
the one thing i would say is gun rights
that i will give uh
reluctantly i'll give the republican
party and conservatism in general
some credit for that the left has not
made
anywhere near the kind of progress
they've tried to make um
in terms of infringing on gun rights
doesn't doesn't mean they're not trying
they're going to keep trying
but you look at at the success they've
had in every other area
especially the areas they've really
focused on usually when they home in on
something and say we're going to win
this issue they win it
and they've been doing that with gun
rights and they have not had that kind
of success that's the one thing i'll say
that in tax cuts i guess
and finally do you think people feel the
way that woman does the woman who
complained about the man in the locker
room
in the video we played yesterday but
just keep quiet to avoid being canceled
well yeah i
i know that people feel that way that
was the whole point yesterday
there are still a lot of sane normal
people in this country i
i would guess that same normal people
still
outnumber the insane people our numbers
are dwindling but we still i believe are
in the majority but most
uh are too afraid to be sane publicly
and then that's how we end up with these
kinds of situations
well if you need a good dose of
uncensored history then
i've got the perfect documentary for you
i've been telling you about this it's
called created equal
and it tells the story of clarence
thomas the second ever
black american supreme court justice to
be confirmed to the highest court in the
land although he doesn't
exactly get the credit for that from the
mainstream media thomas grew up in
the segregated south and built an
esteemed career against all odds he then
found himself in a highly contentious
confirmation battle
that almost tore apart his family and
ruined his reputation it's an absolutely
riveting
documentary and it's only available to
daily wire members so if you want more
stories
that diverge from the accepted political
narrative you got to go to dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your new
membership with codejustice
and speaking of those kinds of stories
you know once upon a time brave men
uh stood up against tyrannical
governments and fought for the country
that we know and love
and too often those stories fade into
the past to make way for
the culture war obsessed dialogue of
today so in honor of our nation's
upcoming independence day
we'd like to change that our new podcast
america's forgotten heroes illuminates
the intense and action-packed stories of
seven men who fought against all odds to
make america as free as it is today
from john paul jones the father of the
us navy to frank luke the 21 year old
ace pilot who took down 18 german
aircrafts
in 18 days during world war ii these
brave men
are the reason people like me are able
to voice our opinions today
and as we get uh close to july 4th
there's no better time to check this out
so you got to check out
america's forgotten heroes and uh and
experience that story today and remember
if you like what you hear and you
download the podcast remember we leave a
five star review
and uh help share these incredible
stories now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today we must cancel a group called
gen z grow our platform
they're in organization of alleged
republican grassroots activists in
generation z and their mission is to
as the name suggests grow the platform
and forge a new and young and exciting
and fresh path for the gop but one thing
you notice about the plans to forge a
new and exciting
and fresh new path for the gop is that
the new and exciting and fresh new path
always tends to look and sound an awful
lot like the old path
every couple of years someone comes
along with a big idea for how to help
the republican party get with the times
and connect with the youth and
invariably the big idea is for it to
basically continue doing what it's been
doing all along
so the group put out an ad yesterday
which got some attention online let's
take a look at that
we are generation z
we are the most creative and eager
generation
despite all of the memes and contrary to
popular belief
we are not automatically democrats
sometimes
they just feel like they're the only
option equality education
the environment and entrepreneurship the
four e's that are key to preserving the
gop
in the long run we're the most diverse
generation
in american history above all we are the
generation
ready to lead our country to a brighter
future in the 21st century
let me introduce you to some of my
friends we're going to show you how
we're going to do this
on the conservative side of the aisle
you know we talk a lot about equality
but conservatives need to be engaged
this means promoting an equality of
opportunity for all voices
no more litmus tests give people the
freedom and security to live their own
lives
as an immigrant from cote d'ivoire i
have benefited from world class
education
right here in america it will help me
achieve my dreams
and eventually attain my citizenship but
my story is exception
not the rule we need to pursue education
reforms that lift up
all students right here in the united
states i grew up
in the rural midwest i saw firsthand the
importance of a natural environment
not only does it matter to the
livelihood of millions of american
farmers
but it's also god's creation and which
we have a moral obligation to protect
gen z is independent we think freely
but in order to fulfill our full
potential we need the tools and climate
to pursue our passions
fulfill our dreams and enact positive
change
if we want to preserve the freedom and
security that we love
while winning the ideological battle
against the left
we must grow gen z's platform on the
right
can we at least get some like stylish
and cool young people if we're gonna do
this
can't even get that well this is pretty
wild stuff so apparently what they're
saying
is that the republican party should talk
about things like
equality and opportunity and respecting
the environment truly
no one has ever devised such a
revolutionary plan as this
these kids are trailblazers it's not as
though
literally every politician constantly
yammers about all of those things
already
so bringing things back to reality it's
true of course that education
is an important issue but a phrase like
we need to pursue education reforms that
lift up all students
is meaningless the word reform is
meaningless
every politician wants to reform
everything but nothing ever happens
apparently reform involves standing in
front of a thing that you want to reform
and just shouting the word reform at it
and with education especially we are way
past the point where mere reform can
solve the problem anyway
this is like suggesting that somebody
with stage four
skin cancer simply needs to wear more
sunscreen
that advice would have been helpful a
long time ago but now
far more drastic measures are needed
what the republican party needs to be
talking about is how to extricate
american families
from their dependence on the government
school system
that is the problem now that's the kind
of reform we need it's a societal reform
at the deepest level and it will require
massive lifestyle changes for millions
of people so it is difficult
but it's necessary and it's also a truly
revolutionary and
bold message and an exciting message
because we're talking about transforming
society
it's a message that says no don't reform
the government education system
dismantle it tear it to the ground
gather up the pieces
and throw them into the sea and let no
one ever speak its name again
that should be our educational message
what are the other ease
the environment well the problem there
is that nobody cares about that
i'm here to tell you right now nobody
cares about the environment
okay few people will admit it
but nobody really cares i don't really
care
i don't think about it at all even the
people who pretend to care
don't really people generally understand
that you shouldn't litter
you shouldn't engage in the wanton
destruction of nature for no reason but
nobody's making significant and dramatic
changes to their lives in order to save
the environment or whatever
nobody's doing that or will do that
and that's okay because the environment
will be okay the planet is a pretty
resilient thing it's been around for
over four billion years
it's survived asteroids and super
volcano eruptions and many other
calamities it'll be fine
this isn't something we need to spend
time talking about and anyway like i
said
nobody actually cares
what about equality well here's another
thing that conservatives
don't need to talk about what is
equality anyway what kind of equality do
we want
is equality some sort of universal good
no
it's not a universal good and it's not
universally attainable
the only kind of equality that we need
to worry about
is equality under the law there
shouldn't be any laws which
target or disenfranchise people based on
race sex etc
the good news is that there are no such
laws targeting racial minorities or any
other approved victim group with the
exception of asians
the bad news is that there are laws like
affirmative action
which intentionally disadvantage white
people and asians and we should be
talking about that but but not by
turning it into a broad stroke
discussion
about equality and then there's
entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship um sure
entrepreneurship is good
we want more of that and we want to
protect small business owners and all of
that and yada yada
um but are any of these issues the sorts
of issues that really drive
people at the deepest level are these
the things that stir men's souls
are people lying awake at night tossing
and turning worried about these kinds of
things
are people sitting at their kitchen
tables right now you know furrowing
their brows
rubbing their temples fretting about
whether we have the right environmental
policies in place
no is anyone going to see that ad that i
just played and feel fired up and ready
to charge into battle eager to fight for
the soul of our nation
no we live in a country
where life sanity
reason virtue science
truth are all under attack
at the most fundamental level our nation
itself our sovereignty hangs in the
balance
the most powerful forces in our culture
from government to academia to media to
corporate america
are all conspiring in this assault and
that
is what worries people that's what keeps
people awake at night young and old and
in between
i know because they tell me all the time
these are not academic issues either
these are real and tangible and these
are things
that republican leaders and lawmakers
could be doing something
to stop they could be addressing it
we could have laws in place around all
of these issues
but we're not doing anything and and
that's what the conservative movement of
the future
should be focused on if it's not focused
on that then it might as well put up the
white flag and surrender and that's what
this ad is really proposing in so many
words
what it's really saying is there's a lot
of words to really just say
give up
and that's why the ad and those
responsible for it
are as tradition dictates cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. today on the
ben shapiro show according to espn
a woman is a he a she and also a them
we'll talk about it today on the bench
restaurant give it a listen